let's take a short break, uh, from the Iran
stuff, which we will get back to because it's
so important.
I want to briefly talk about some of the developments
in the 2020 democratic primary and the developments
are that Bernie Sanders has surged into first
place, either tied for first or alone in first
in both of the early primary States, Iowa
and New Hampshire.
So we've got the next democratic debate on
January 14th we'll be covering it live.
Then voting will start in Iowa soon thereafter.
We're, we're really almost in the thick of
this and coming on the heels of record fundraising
for Bernie Sanders in the fourth quarter of
2019 his latest early state polls are looking
very solid.
Let's look briefly at national polls.
You'll notice Bernie Sanders in second place
over Elizabeth Warren in every recent poll.
Sometimes he's ahead by one within the margin
of error.
Sometimes he's ahead of Elizabeth Warren by
five sometimes in one poll, Bernie Sanders
is ahead by 13 of Elizabeth Warren in a, the
latest Emerson poll.
Still Joe Biden in first place in these polls.
But what about early States?
We finally have new polling from Iowa.
The latest CBS YouGov poll in Iowa has a three
way tie for first place between Bernie Sanders,
Pete boot edge edge, and Joe Biden.
Remember that Buddha judge had been doing
very well in Iowa.
Now a three way tie.
Then we look at New Hampshire, which is the
second state to vote, where the latest CBS
YouGov poll has Bernie ahead of Biden 27 to
25 it's within the margin of error, but a
very solid showing for Bernie Sanders.
Now we have to give the normal caveats.
We have one recent poll from of those States
in the last month.
Otherwise, we really don't have enough polling.
We should have more data.
We don't, but this is what we have.
Things are looking predictably less good for
Bernie Sanders in the third and fourth States
to vote.
For example, in Nevada, which votes third?
Bernie is tied for second, but again, these
are old polls.
We have nothing in Nevada since mid November.
Anything could have changed there.
Similar situation in South Carolina.
Bernie, not expected to win South Carolina,
but again, no polling since the first half
of December.
At that point, Joe Biden was comfortably ahead,
so key dates upcoming in this race.
We have a January 10th just a few days from
now is the deadline to qualify for debate
number seven January 14th we will have debate
number seven and then on February 3rd we will
have the Iowa caucuses.
February 7th is the eighth democratic debate
followed just a few days later on February
11th by the New Hampshire primary, a little
over a week later, February 19th we will have
the ninth the democratic debate and then we
will have the Nevada caucuses on February
22nd the 10th the democratic debate just three
days later on February 25th and then on February
29th leap year, it is the South Carolina primary
and then just a few days later, March 3rd
super Tuesday where there will be 14 primaries.
It is conceivable, it's conceivable that by
March 3rd we will be able to say with great
certainty who the nominee will be.
It's not guaranteed, but there's a good chance
that by the morning of March 4th, let's put
it that way, we will be able to probably have
a sense of who the democratic nominee will
be.
Uh, and that is less than two months from
now.
So we are planning to keep a pretty busy schedule.
I plan to cover all of the debates live.
I plan to live stream results on all of those
voting days as well as analysis on caucus
and primary days.
We have some upcoming travel.
I'm trying to schedule it all around these
dates that I showed you so that we can be
here for everything because it matters and
we are going to be here.
We'll be here in the lead up to the war with
Iran if indeed we are going to have one and
we will be here throughout the entire primary
and convention and general election process.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure to give us a like on Facebook at
facebook.com/david Pakman show.
We will talk next.
Hey guys, how are you?
We have a be able to afford the war with Iran.
Oh, right.
Nobody's asking that question because they
don't care.
Back right after this